Martyna Fordham is a global chief
political analyst at City so Tina Angle
hariya they're comparing brexit with the
Blitz is he overdoing the doom and gloom
a bit do you think well they're
certainly using strong language to make
an important point but the headline
number in the OECD report was pretty
compelling 40 billion off of GDP that's
an attention-getter I mean should we be
too bothered about what the OECD says I
mean after all let's not forget it
campaigned for the UK to remain in the
EU and go hariya was a very outspoken
exponent of remaining in the EU
well should we care I mean it tells you
something about the state of thinking in
the sort of the world's leading
economies of which the UK is still one
before I came on I read through the
Twitter feed for the OECD and looked at
some of the comments and predictably it
was a lot of what they would say that
wouldn't they and trying to deprive us
of our glorious brexit but to a certain
extent when we combine the fact that
we've got recent reports about the
impact on on FDI we see that inflation
continues to go up one of your
commentators in in that clip talked
about the effect of a weak pound helps
some businesses but not others it starts
to be clear in the midst of what is a
coordinated modest global recovery that
there there is an impact for the UK and
of course brexit hasn't actually
happened yet
CIBC DS forecasting record like I mean
is it I mean it submitted in the past it
got a lot of its forecasting wrong
during the eurozone sovereign debt
crisis for example well I'm a political
scientist and and we have our own
differences with economists who you know
famously predict 15 of the last ten
recessions and and everything else but
in this post truth post factual world
I'm not sure that it's it's wise to
discount the the thinking from these
leading forecasters and again the UK is
slower compared to its other peers at
least in in the European Union there's
also something as subtle as the effect
on business confidence which is
nearer to what I do in my day job now
the OECD is calling for a second
referendum I know this is pretty
unrealistic though isn't it well they're
not calling for a second referendum and
what they've said is if they're if
brexit were to be reversed there would
be a boost to growth and and you know to
my way of thinking that's classic
economist way of not understanding that
the politics involved so if brexit were
to sort of just disappear from the scene
somehow if we were to be a do-over or we
were to wake up and all be a bad dream
there would be a growth effect a rebound
the trouble is and and this is you know
what I'm focused on how exactly would
that come about it's very difficult to
imagine a do-over go ahead cry no it's
going to say I mean you spend an awful
lot of time on the road talking to
clients talking to investors I mean what
are they telling you about their
expectations of brexit right now where
are we in the negotiating stage well
I'll tell you one thing with all of the
geopolitical risks in the world whether
it's North Korea or Donald Trump
developments in Iraq potentially
impacting energy prices European
political risk Catalonia the the self
you know the self imposed state of
brexit starts to seem like a footnote in
a wider panoply of global political risk
so it's a problem for the UK it's a
problem for UK investors and also UK
companies on a trip to Asia no questions
about brexit so it's just not being
discussed anywhere else in the world
it's confusing to to the rest of the
world it's been confusing I think to
many of us who who are living here
trying to you know to to tease out the
headlines and where things might go but
what I know is that when investors don't
understand the political risks they tend
to discount them and in the case of UK
companies that means they power on with
contingency planning because it's hard
to understand when a signal might come
and you mentioned some of the other
political risks in the world right now
how do you gauge where America is in
terms of its outlook towards free trade
right now I'm the pictures we're in the
midst of renegotiating NAFTA yeah
the United States and and the UK are
both experimenting with reversing
decades of globalization that we know
globalization has a lot to answer for
and that's something that I addressed in
my Vox Populi thesis you know over these
many years it's something that that
people in the advanced economies
increasingly feel they are losers from
but we also know that a global trade has
has lifted tens of millions out of out
of poverty and improved living standards
so improving globalization is something
that would seem to be prudent but it's
not exactly just a lever that you can
pull I guess another analogy between the
US and UK is that there appear to be
call all of divisions within the
government in both cases yes some have
suggested that the the political risks
in the advanced economies that I'm
increasingly talking about these days
are really UK u.s. problems that
populism in 2016 really materialized in
the form of brexit and Donald Trump and
here in in you know 2017 we've gone
through European elections with
mainstream parties coming in first place
at least in most cases one interesting
way to think about that though is in
terms of social spending both the UK and
US compared to other OECD countries
speaking of that institution tend to
spend less per capita all right Tina
Fordham from Citi always good to have
you on thanks for joining thank you